the corona virus outbreak in New York
City in the United States is so severe
that White House officials have called
on anyone who has recently left the city
to self isolate for two weeks more than
15,000 cases have been confirmed in New
York and around 200 deaths it's been in
lockdown since Sunday and state
officials are pleading for help but
preparing for the worst people in one of
America's most densely populated cities
have largely vanished from sight they're
either following orders to stay home or
they've left the city those who have are
now being asked to self quarantine for
14 days
that's because nearly half of all US
kovat 19 cases are in New York State
officials there say the figure could
double every three days that would mean
in less than one week New York could
have more cases than all of China State
Governor Andrew Cuomo was blunt about
the quote troubling and astronomical
rise in numbers we're not slowing it and
it is accelerating on its own we were
looking at a freight train coming across
the country we're now looking at a
bullet train because the numbers are
going up that quickly Cuomo said New
York may need as many as 40,000
intensive care unit beds in the next few
weeks it has just three thousand he
asked the federal government to send as
many as 20,000 ventilators the Trump
administration has said it's sending
4,000 and that the private sector is
stepping up to meet the crisis we're
receiving full cooperation from
companies with the understanding that
the federal government stands ready to
compel cooperation if need be we haven't
found that to be the case
Ford 3m and GE have all said they're
looking at ways to boost production of
masks and other critical supplies for
health workers the pandemics economic
impact may dwarf previous crises Trump
officials have said up to six trillion
dollars in relief more than the entire
2020 federal budget may become available
as Congress works towards a compromise
on an economic rescue plan liquidity and
cash for families small business
individuals unemployed to keep this
thing going we're heading for a rough
period but it's only gonna be weeks we
think weeks months not gonna be years
that's for sure what's for sure is a
moving target a rapidly spreading
outbreak means more airplane sit empty
while more hospitals fill up with no
clear end in sight all the massive
stimulus package you just heard about
currently going through Congress has got
Wall Street excited the Dow Jones search
by more than 11 percent on Tuesday -
biggest gain since 1933 right now Asian
markets are following suit chairs in
Tokyo have jumped by more than five and
a half percent Shanghai and Hong Kong
exchanges are also seeing gains among
the items agreed adults could receive
direct deposits of up to twelve hundred
dollars five hundred dollars for
children the government will support
small businesses with loans to the tune
of three hundred and sixty seven billion
dollars and hospitals will receive
around one hundred and fifty billion in
aid and also be half a trillion in
guaranteed subsidized loans to larger
businesses a more from DW financial
reporter Chelsey Delaney in Frankfort
welcome Chelsea so how does this package
differ from the one that was voted down
on Monday well we're still awaiting the
the full text of this bill that's
expected later in the day but one of the
big sticking points have been oversight
of this five hundred billion dollars
that's going to be helping big business
Democrats wanted there to be more
oversight of that and it does appear
that they have gotten a concession on
that the Democrats have said that then
money especially the fifty billion
dollars it's gonna go directly to
Airlines this is going to be overseen by
a congressional panel and the Inspector
General some of the other changes that
that Democrats got through this
negotiation process was more money for
local and state governments more money
for the the health care and hospital
system and also stronger unemployment
measures for people who lose their jobs
through this crisis so previously there
had been three months of unemployment
insurance now they're going to
four and this can also be extended to
two gig economy workers to something
like an uber driver and how markets
reacting well the docks just opened up
here in Frankfurt it's up about 2.5
percent right now
Wall Street futures are also pointing a
bit higher it's hard to tell right now
if this is going to be the beginning of
a longer upswing for markets but there's
clearly been a disconnect in the past
few days between the the really dire
numbers we're seeing in terms of the
spread of this virus and the economic
damage and these big gains in stock
markets as people focused on stimulus
the stimulus measures are crucial
they're going to be huge and it's going
to help businesses and then workers get
through this crisis but I think they're
there now that governments have sort of
played their hand investors are going to
go back to focusing on the reality of
the situation which is that the outbreak
is not contained we don't know how long
these shotgun shutdowns are gonna last
and what the economic damage is really
going to be Josie Delaney in Frankfort
thank you so let's join the DW financial
correspondent song han-soo in Taipei
welcome sir
Asian markets have been up for two days
does this mean things are looking better
now well some positive emerged and we
see Asian markets were up after the US
Federal Reserve promised support to this
struggling economy and the US Congress
is close to this two trillion dollar aid
package so many traders they are
encouraged by this promises but most
Asian investors they're still worried
that the worst of the cup in 19 has yet
to come and they they believe that you
will ultimately lead to exit price
inflation and financial repression it
makes sense because it takes a leap of
faith when we see companies losing 50 to
90 percent of their earnings and faced
difficult situation so we can expect an
uncertain period for the next six to 12
months okay so what about China they've
lifted the travel ban in Huub a province
where the pandemic began and more and
more people are going back to work so
does this mean the coronavirus is under
control there
well in a way yes but many people are
skeptical about the real situation in
China and the people are watching
closely to see if there will be the
second wave of this outbreak and it's
difficult for any leader now to tell the
people to chillax because this pandemic
has just cost too serious other damages
health crises leading to a crisis
confidence and leading to consumption
collapsing and demand destruction and
economic crisis so it just takes a lot
of effort for people to regain
confidence so it's just a very difficult
time now even for China
so enhancer in Taipei thank you let's
just said travel restrictions in China
are being lifted from today and who may
profits where the corona virus pandemic
began in December
trains have started running again
although they're not yet carrying many
passengers stations are opening up
across the province except in the city
of Wuhan where the corona virus was
first detected the car drivers there are
still being tested and it'll be another
two weeks before Wuhan sees its
restrictions lifted it's not only in who
Bay where people are now free to go out
and about on family in Beijing is
relishing the freedom to roam after
weeks cooped up in their apartment jokai
is finally allowed to run around again
he and his family spent seven weeks in
voluntary lockdown in their Beijing
apartment his mother and grandmother are
still uneasy and wear masks like
everyone else but at least they can
finally go outside I'm so happy it can
really drive you crazy
I was indoors for almost two months it's
especially hard on children we adults
are able to deal with it better but
staying home this long is not healthy
for the body or the mind
but joke eyes daily routine still
excludes other children schools remain
closed and play dates are still
off-limits it doesn't really feel that
unusual but I do miss playing with my
friends
me and little get out on the streets
there are more signs of life much less
than before the coronavirus but Beijing
no longer resembles a ghost town China's
leadership now plans to restart the
economy on state-run television premier
Lee speaks via videoconference with
Chinese companies China is facing a
major downturn in its export sector and
in retail the service industry in major
cities is also experiencing a slump says
economics expert Dan Wang overall many
businesses are not yet operating
normally China's leadership wants to
speed things up but there's some
pushback central government is trying
everything they could to urge people to
go back to work
but when it comes to local governments
they have every incentive to prevent
people and the factories from back to
full capacity for simple reason if the
infection cases go up their political
career is over and experts warn that a
new wave of infections in China is
unavoidable everyone's on the alert for
the start of the second wave given that
there are these importations it's only a
matter of time before spread occurs in
the local community and then the numbers
rise and then it becomes detected so I
don't know how long that will take in
China but it will happen in Beijing
people are ready to venture out into
parks to get some exercise or just to
take a stroll in the fresh air joke eyes
family is also worried about another
wave of infections that's why he's still
not allowed to meet up with his friends
a normal boy in a major city that's
still far from being back to normal
let's get more from journalist to Fabian
Kretschmer in Beijing
welcome Fabian well life in China does
seem to be returning to normal so it's
the crisis they're really over no no no
actually we have to be careful with the
word normal what we see is not normal
and compared to what we had before the
virus or is it normal that for example
if me when I go visit Shanghai I have to
parent him for 14 days then if I would
return back to Beijing also again
guarantee for 40 days here in Beijing
even though you can see traffic is
getting congested again even subways are
slowly filling up restaurants are
opening up so yes there's some kind of
normal everyday life but still
everywhere you go you have to show that
you were wearing a face mask you have to
get your temperature scanned and yes and
we should not be too optimistic I mean
this whole yeah security or safety that
we have right now you can only keep that
because of all the travel bans because
everyone who comes from foreign
countries wants to go to the capital
here in Beijing they have to go to a
centralized quarantine station that's
there are hotels you cannot leave your
room there and that's how they try to
keep the country a virus free but we
also know that there are many so called
asymptotic cases infected persons who
don't show any symptoms and they are not
counted here in the statistics so
actually it's only a matter of time
until the virus yeah might react you
also in China again